and I'm pleased that today we have
agreed that we will expand our training
program a program that has trained 10
000 troops in the last six months alone
to your Marines and fighter jet Pilots
ensuring the Armed Forces of Ukraine are
able to defend their country for
generations to come
we must arm Ukraine in the short term
but we must bolster Ukraine for the long
term
your country cannot be left vulnerable
to attack ever again
today we have signed the London
declaration further deepening our
cooperation and in the coming days
we will Mark a year
since this needless and unprovoked
Invasion and Russia will see more than
ever
that their tactics
are only solidifying Western resolve
only convincing us to go further and
faster to help you Vladimir and we will
after all you told me last week that
Collective International Unity is your
greatest weapon and you can be sure that
we will deliver on that not just now but
long into the future
thank you so much
um prime minister name
um
the dear prime minister the Prime
Minister the journalists their
participants
today together
on our negotiations and this is exactly
here on this military base with our
Ukrainian Awards
and we began this day with some
different issues together with them and
then obviously we also continue
discussing this defense issues in my
address to the British Parliament and we
are closing this day
we have a very strong defense package
from Great Britain we've already
received a significant number of our
materials
and also the training of our great
and for the decisions that are truly
helping our Ukrainian Warriors to become
stronger I'm also grateful to his
majesty foreign
[Music]
we've also discussed our position on the
international platform
350 days of unity glory to Ukraine thank
you so much thank you Vladimir thank you
for the kind words I think we have some
time for a few questions from the media
can we start with ITV News
is there someone here
hello uh Rohit cat tree from ITV
um Mr President first of all you've made
a broad and emotional appeal today for
further support but I think a lot of
British people want to know some of the
specifics for example when do you
believe this Russian offensive will
happen how many fighter jets do you need
when do you need them and what happens
if you don't get them and to you Mr
Prime Minister you seem to be inching
towards a position of being able to
provide fighter jets towards for the
ukrainians can can you offer absolute
Clarity here and now will they get them
and if so when
thanks Rohit for the question why don't
I start and then uh I'll do that Vlog me
so I think look first of all we've been
very clear and we've been clear for a
long time that when it comes to the
provision of military assistance to
Ukraine nothing is off the table and
that's because we're determined to
ensure that Vladimir the president and
his people can be victorious against
Russian aggression and we've backed up
that rhetoric with action last year
behind the United States we were the
single largest donor of military
equipment to Ukraine and we said that we
would match or exceed that amount almost
two and a half billion pounds again this
year and you saw when it came to the
provision of main battle tanks we were
the first G7 Nation I announced that
weeks ago something that President and I
had discussed previously it was
important in order to ensure that
Ukraine can make progress on the
battlefield and I think we helped lead
an international conversation which led
to many other countries following us and
providing main battle tanks to Ukraine
so when it comes to fighter combat
aircraft of course they are part of the
conversation indeed we've been
discussing that today and have been
previously and that's why we've
announced today that we will be training
Ukrainian Air Force on NATO standard
platforms because the first step in
being able to provide Advanced aircrafts
is to have soldiers or aviators that are
capable of using them that is a process
it takes some time we've started that
process today that's because we're keen
to support the president and his country
in delivering a victory and nothing is
off the table and our leadership on this
issue is something that we all
collectively should be very proud of and
I know that the president is grateful
for
thank you thank you very much thank you
for your question
with regards to the equipment with the
equipment that we need of course there's
a lot of equipment we need and a lot of
different equipment it all depends on
the situation depends on the situation
on the battlefield on the dead kind of
in the military Direction but also
depends on what's happening within the
country you know how we are fighting
against the Iranian drones you know
there are hundreds of thousands
fighting against them by various means
and that includes also a ballistic
missiles because this animals
infrastructure educational
infrastructure hospitals
because they are trying to threaten
ukrainians but they're trying to make
them flee by ukrainians are not going to
once people work obviously this money
they'll not just go to for pensions or
other social welfare but also this also
goes to support our Warriors that's why
it's very important that we have
everything needed to support people in
their jobs and when we talk about the
battlefield what are priorities of
course armored vehicles you know we know
that our enemy has got ourselves since
units of armored vehicles you know back
from the uh back from the Soviet Union
Heritage and of course nature armored
vehicles they are the best and yet there
are only few
and obviously we've spent a lot of time
talking about this together and you've
just heard what uh
today and tomorrow we will be meeting
with the EU leaders and discussing them
issues and also a longer range missiles
that's our priority and I'm very
grateful that Britain has finally heard
us in that regard and I do hope that all
the countries will also hear us when it
comes to a longer range missiles you
know because we do need to push back the
Russians so people can just live yes
has never happened you know it's just
been a different kind of intensity
so all we need to think is that let us
make Russians think about Ukrainian
counter offensive okay they need to be
thinking about this they need to be
thinking how they should be living our
territory that's all I would like to
share with you thank you thank you
Vladimir next can I call on BBC Ukraine
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
soldiers they are dying every day don't
you think that that decision about
workplace is taking too long and uh yeah
and the other question is what are your
steps to clear the reputation of London
as a city that is still laundering
Russian money thank you thanks
so with I think you heard from the
president's previous answer Natalia
about the very immediate needs and
that's air defense and long-range
missiles and that's the conversation
that we've been having most recently
about how can we provide air defense to
protect the Ukrainian population that
has been the thing that we've talked
about probably most in all of our
conversations which is why we've
provided
thousands of surface-to-air missiles and
air defense systems and will continue to
do so and more are coming over the next
few weeks and as the president said
probably the most crucial capability
right here and now is main battle tanks
which we LED on but also those
long-range missiles uh that I think that
and all the the talking that we've done
and the planning for how we can have
decisive Victory on the battlefield and
make progress it requires long-range
missiles which currently the range is
not there and again that's the
conversation that we've been having and
again we hope that Britain can lead but
when it comes to protecting soldiers I
think we we feel very acutely the
tragedy and the hardship that your
country and your country men are going
through and I you know we've both had
the privilege of meeting some of them
today I've met some of them in the past
and their bravery is inspiring it's
awe-inspiring to see as I have you know
the ordinary citizens young young men
and women who are fighting to defend
their country three and being trained to
do so here and they go with not just our
wishes and our training but they go with
our full support with all the equipment
that we can continue to provide them and
we'll continue to do so but rest assured
we are here with you with your people
and continue to provide you with
whatever we can to ensure their safety
and indeed their success
with regard to sanctions I think we've
as you as you saw at the beginning of
this conflict I used to be the Finance
Minister and we put in place the
president talked about it earlier today
probably the most extensive and
forward-leaning sanctions package of any
country at the beginning of this
conflict to demonstrate very clearly
that Russia's aggression was
unacceptable and we would punish them in
every which way we could we've announced
further sanctions today but continually
when it comes to sanctions uh we have I
think LED and you remember the
conversations we had on on things like
Swift and Banks right at the beginning
of this conflict again it was Britain
that led the way in pushing for very
strict sanctions and and as we've
announced further today and wherever we
can continue you know to tighten them
and do more we will look to do so as we
have done today
uh next uh can we go to Sky News please
thank you Dominic wagorn Sky News prime
minister if I could ask you first of all
there does seem to have been a a lag
between Ukraine asking for more
sophisticated weaponry and it eventually
being given they are some more advanced
artillery it was eventually sent they've
asked for tanks and they will be sent
eventually they now want fighter jets
and we're training their pilots but
we're not sending the Jets your
predecessor one of your predecessors a
close friend of president zielinski has
has wondered why we're not doing more
why not send more so they can finish off
the job now what is holding the west
back why is there that lag Mr President
good to see you again if I could ask you
about fighter jets how urgently do you
need them and what does it mean for your
country if you don't get them
so I mean I'll I'll take that there's
the first question and again I probably
slightly the the
notion of the question because I think
we have continually LED actually in the
UK with a provision of equipment to
Ukraine and whether it was right at the
beginning with anti-tank missiles
whether as you heard from the president
the importance of armored vehicles I
think we've sent hundreds uh whether
it's artillery guns again in the next
few weeks a new set of batteries of
artillery guns will arrive at tanks
we've already talked about and we're
training combat aircraft for the first
time indeed actually something that we
should have probably been doing a long
time ago because we have a long-standing
training relationship with Ukraine that
predates the war but that is something
as we look forward we'll want to
continue to do more of as we want to
make sure that the Ukrainian armed
forces are trained on NATO standard
equipment and there's greater
interoperability between Ukraine and
NATO which is very much something that
we've been discussing so I think sure
we've continued to be on the forward
Leading Edge of it and we're providing
things as quickly as we can that the the
the Challenger tanks are going to be on
the battlefield as I said in a matter of
weeks I mean you've seen the Ukrainian
soldiers being trained on them as fast
as we can and we're providing them as
fast as we can and we know that they
will they will make a difference and I
think the president would tell you you
know we've been having conversations for
the few months that I've had this job
and relatively rapidly after we discuss
what is necessary either Ukraine sees
that we do respond and then we Galvanize
others to respond to that's what we have
done and that's what we'll continue to
do
and for our worries and also Great
Britain providing equipment and here
we're talking about seven lines as well
and then people had to rise up and they
had to fight with what they had you know
we're not doing any self-peating here
okay what they had they were doing and
we were just grateful to for whatever we
were getting and then we turned another
page
and then we turned into food
we all turned into fury because
Russians were just killing and ordering
eight people and they were raping people
and we were ready to have anything in
use any kind of weapons just to destroy
them and then we turned another page
artillery you know we needed artillery
to work in a different direction and
this is exactly where we received as
somehow
forward
I think it's very important to
understand that Russia has no pity for
their own people they just keep on
throwing their people in to the
battlefield you know we have pity and we
it's a project people we would not throw
them just prepared
and that kind of marketed different
stage in the world
directions
there will be stagnation
a nuclear
stations
that we are discussing now
which will not bring to anything good
thank you next we have inter
good evening Mr Prime Minister
President press conferences
Ukraine you know in a different country
just under the peaceful sky so what are
your personal impressions
and what threatens me back at home
you know yes this is my second visit
outside of Ukraine after the beginning
of the uh Russian
you know what I had to do two important
things
and first of all to express our deep
gratitude
all the Ukrainian people to the people
of
Christine has been so active in this
fight yes
we should not be forgetting
we could have lost our independence
battalions and foreign
it just doesn't happen overnight
um
[Music]
yet the war has not ended foreign
thank you uh prime minister
um you say that Britain led the world
rightly on training Ukrainian troops
um on providing arms and you yourself on
tanks but there does seem to be a
reticent to break ranks with the Western
allies on jets are you personally
willing as prime minister if you can to
send Ukraine some of our typhoon Fleet
and Mr President on behalf of millions
of sun readers I just like to say
welcome and Slava Ukraine Boris Johnson
says there's no conceivable reason for
Britain and the West not to send you
Jets what are the reasons that they're
telling you privately and are those
reasons credible thank you very much
both
uh so I think you're totally wrong to
say that there's been any reticence
actually we we were the first
G7 country to provide main battle tanks
we were also the first country to
provide serious arms to Ukraine at the
beginning and we we have genuinely LED
other countries and that's something we
should all be very proud of and when it
comes to the Quantum of our support
Second only to the United States last
year and again a commitment to provide
the same or more this year uh and then
there's also as well as the the things
that we provide there's also the and I
think the president would attest to this
the very close cooperation engagement
between our teams as to how that Ukraine
can be successful with all the support
and training as you're seeing here but
also the help that we provide across the
board so I don't think there's been any
reticence at all actually and we've
probably been the most forward-leaning
country in trying to bring about a
Ukrainian victory in this conflict and
that's why as prime minister we decided
to change our strategy to accelerate and
intensify the amount of support that we
give Ukraine so that we can bring up
about more decisive victory in a sooner
period of time and that's why we I made
the decision to provide tax and with
regret with regard to aircraft as I said
we've already said nothing is off the
table and the first step on that has to
be to have a people who can fly what are
very sophisticated pieces of Kit I mean
from start if you take someone who's
brand new for a fighter jet as as
vlogger would also say it takes three
years and obviously that's not what
we're working with because Ukraine has
existing fighter pilots but we do need
to make sure that they can operate the
aircraft that they could potentially be
using but also there's a supply chain
around such sophisticated aircraft those
are the conversations that the president
and I are having are making sure that we
understand all the supply chain needs
that go along alongside aircraft like
that making sure that they can be used
and used safely and kept safely so we're
having that conversation and it's also a
conversation we are having with our
allies because particularly some of the
aircraft that we have are are done
through joint treaty with multiple other
trees and I think we've seen that with
previous bits of kit that have others
have had to give for aircraft that is
something that we are we are also
involved in because we have as I said
there are other allies involved in the
provision of those bits of equipment and
as the president said he's on his way to
Europe after this to pick up this
conversation with our partners and
allies over there but where we can
throughout this conflict we have been
nothing but out in front and proud
proudly so and I know the difference
that it's making and I'm I know the
president is grateful for it and that's
what we will continue to do
rejection
s
just on the decisions
come on we will be sending you Pilots
who've already trained for two and a
half years you know
people accelerate the last bit yeah
thank you and I think on that point
another example of it is the
conversation we're having on long range
missiles where again the conversation
that we're having is one that is I think
out in front of other allies about
making sure Ukraine has the longer range
capabilities that it needs at this phase
of the battle and that's a very
productive conversation that that we're
having today as well
good fantastic well thank you very much
for your questions
[Applause]